pas bonjour bonjour à toute bonjour à
tous aujourd'hui c'est un très gros
on est le samedi 16 juin 2010 8 et le
samedi 16 juin 2018 il ya deux
événements hyper important le tout
premier c'est la simple aurélien vous le
saviez peut-être pas c'est donc que j'en
appelle aux bonnes fêtes un bras je suis
très content c'est toujours un événement
que j'ai fait un petit peu tout seul
chaque année entre-temps le fit avec
vous et puis le deuxième point super
importante c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
premier jour de l'équipe de france de
football dans le mondial 2018 en russie
premier match contre l'australie tout à
l'heure pas tout à l'heure ça les corps
qu'il a regardé la vidéo mais l'or avec
elle je la fais est alors à laquelle je
l'a publié là il est quelque chose comme
8h17
8h17 1 8h17 il est 8 heures 18 on est le
samedi 16 jeunes on voyait je suis hyper
hyper hyper alors pour vous parler
aujourd'hui la coupe du monde de
football et du match de l'équipe de
france mais j'ai pas besoin par une
porte tout le monde parce que c'est une
chaîne qui parle de teck donc arrivé
d'un coup
et parler foot on n'y comprend plus rien
je vais vous parler aujourd'hui de teck
de football et tout ça on prend et on
mélange ensemble parce que à l'occasion
de la coupe du monde de football 2018
vous allez pouvoir gagner des produits
tech un iphone cet ipad 9,7 pouces une
ps4 tout ça en faisant des pronostics
gratuits alors je vous explique comment
ça marche c'est mon partenaire ribaille
point fr qui vous organise pendant toute
la coupe du monde
des pronostics gratuit pour vous faire
gagner différents cadeaux et l'idée je
trouve plutôt cool c'est pour ça je
voulais la partager avec vous green bay
pourrait faire ce pas si vous connaissez
un site d'achat d'occasions de produits
reconditionnés les acheter des produits
reconditionnés c'est déjà d'acheter
moins cher
d'abord un vrai geste écologique parce
que ça évite que des produits techno par
exemple hop comme ceci pour ça il est
vraiment vieux pour le coup on va
prendre un truc un petit peu moins vieux
un produit comme ça qu'ils fonctionnent
encore vous allez pouvoir l'acheter déjà
beaucoup trop cher et ça évite qu'ils
finissent dans des belles à être
complètement démonté avec la pollution
sans rejoindre derrière tout ça pour
coup c'est vraiment intéressant ça donne
une nouvelle vie à des produits qui
fonctionnent encore pour savoir quand
même qu'on renouvelle très très très
souvent nos pros technologique alors que
les anciens fonctionne encore donc déjà
vous achetez moins cher et en plus si
vous vendez vos produits ça vous permet
de les vendre et encore d'en tirer un
bon prix plutôt qu'ils finissent comme
moi ici sur un bureau
bon moi je collectionne c'est encore un
petit peu différent mais voyez un petit
peu le principe très très court ribaille
ses leaders européens du marché des
produits électroniques d'occasion en
gros le fonctionnement est hyper simple
vous vous connecter sur leur site vous
liste vous choisissez le produit tel que
vous voulez vendre moi par exemple ici
j'avais vendre un iphone 5 c je
sélectionne devant l'iphone 5 c'est jean
drapeau un petit questionnaire sur
l'étal fonctionnement le cilss as qu'il
en bonne état dont le mien pour le coup
là ils ont dit période et à l'écran est
un petit peu des fonctions dont je ne
pourrais pas le vendre vous vous
répondre à un petit questionnaire de
leurs pouvait bien ensuite vous avez un
bordereau imprimer directement vous
envoyez vos produits gratuitement
rassurez vous ils sont assurés jusqu'à
hauteur de 500 euros de valeur dont vous
est quand même relativement tranquille
ensuite ils reçoivent le produit il
vérifie que tout va bien tout correspond
à une fois que tout est ok il crédit
peuvent compte vous pouvez récupérer
l'argent à faire ce que vous voulez voir
ça c'est pour le fonctionnement et du
court il vaille c'est d'ici pour la
coupe du monde on faisait un jeu sont
organisé un jeu concours autour du
football pour gagner des produits tech
iphone scène je voulais dit un ipad 9,7
pouces et une ps4
et puis plein de bons de réduction pour
acheter sur le titre i bat alors son cou
ses intérêts sans le sou qui est assez
ludique vous gagnez des cadeaux en
donnant vos pronostics sur en tout sept
matches comme far et passe partout
cette clé sur sept matches chaque
pronostique que vous faites vous gagnez
des points que vous ayez le bon
pronostic ou que vous ayez perdu
forcément si vous plantez vous n'allez
pas gagner ou autant de points que celui
calme on pronostique le 16 juillet
l'occasion de la finale il ya un
décompte total des points et la personne
qui arrive en tête repart avec son
iphone 5
ensuite le deuxième c'est l'ipad 7
pouces le troisième set parce qu'enfin
vous avez compris le système pour
résumer vous faites votre pronostic du
jour et en fonction de vos résultats
vous collectionnez des points à la suite
de quoi vous allez partager votre
résultat sur facebook avec le hashtag
mondiale a décrit bague et vous invitez
vos amis vous donner vos pronostics
jusqu'à la fin de la coupe du monde et à
la fin eh bien vous remporter le gros
lot enfin le gros lot ça ça dépend de
vous pour un pronostic exact vous gagnez
3 points trois points
si vous avez donné le nom du vainqueur
du match vous gagnez de points et si
vous êtes complètement planté vous
gagnez quand même un point dans tous les
cas on gagne quelque chose c'est pas mal
d'ailleurs en parlant de pronostic pour
le match france australie
si vous regardez la vidéo avant que le
match ait lieu de tricher pas je vais
regarder l'heure dans les commentaires
leur publication
à votre avis qui va gagner entre la
france et l'australie et qu'elle sera
résultats alors moi je vois bien un bond
de 0 pour la france je sais pas pourquoi
est-ce que je suis chauvin c'est pas
impossible mais je vois bien vous deux
euros pour la france un petit match pour
commencer ce soir de se mettre se mettre
en jambes on va si je me suis planté
jour là franchement ridicule mais c'est
pas bien grave
voilà pour ce plan que je voulais
partager avec vous je vous ai mis à lire
dans la description si vous êtes
intéressés vous pouvez y aller
participer faire vos pronostics rassurez
vous c'est vous coûte absolument rien
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
et puis que le meilleur gagne enfin
j'espère en tout cas que la france va
les [ __ ] encore une bonne fête à moins
d'être est en voyage à bientôt abonnez
vous laissez des coeurs à bientôt
[Musique]